[Musique]
la grande barrière de corail et
merveilles par sa grandeur et sa
biodiversité
mais ce que les scientifiques
craignaient depuis de nombreuses années
est en train de se produire en 25 ans
plus de la moitié de ces coraux ont
disparu selon une étude publiée dans la
revue proceedings of the royal society
ici l'humain ne renverse pas la tendance
la grande barrière deviendra
méconnaissable affirme un des co auteurs
de l'étude
les récifs coralliens sont en train de
disparaître la biologiste marine lyne
morissette est du même avis l'activité
humaine
le réchauffement des océans ont aggravé
la situation
on est vraiment dans une phase aussi on
fait rien que les choses continuent
comme ça il ya de la biodiversité qui va
disparaître
il ya des services qui vont disparaître
aussi en terme d'éco système et puis
tout ça ben c'est de notre faute si
c'est dû au changement climatique
l'éco système a connu plusieurs épisodes
de blanchiment au cours desquelles les
coraux dépérissent et perdent leur
coloration parmi les plus atteints ces
coraux en forme de disque ou de table où
se réfugient bon nombre d'espèces
les récifs pour s en remettre si l'on se
refroidissait mais ils peuvent aussi
mourir si le phénomène persiste
le mieux qu'on puisse faire si on
atteint des cibles ça va être de
ralentir un peu le processus itie
gabriel proulx radio canada montréal